I have a look number one and I see my
biggest issue the first thing I need to
sign up is all this fraction rubbish
okay you've got a divided by 5 by 3
divided by 10 and it's all a bit of a
mess so before i do any like [ __ ]
things from different sides collecting
like terms etc I want to get rid of all
of these three it'd be really nice if i
could multiply through by a single
number that'll get rid of all of them
any suggestions
I'd like to multiply through I don't
have to I can do some multiple steps but
I'd like to multiply through by a single
number that will get rid of dividing by
5 dividing by 3 and dividing by 10 okay
now multiplying everything by 30 is
going to be it's not the only way but it
will certainly be the quickest way i
would say probably our most comment
other thing is you may be x 150 150 is 5
times 3 times 10 and that'll work just
fine you just get enormous numbers that
get to cancel out later so let's try
this out if you didn't multiply through
by 30 keys made giving it a go 3x on
five that 30 and the 5 on the bottom
they'll cancel leaving one what les gets
up a home a six right so it's going 46
lots of that 3x number one so six lots
of 3 x's 18 x okay with that when I do
30 times our third for 30th of three
will cancel again leaving behind a
number which is which is 10 and then on
the right hand side 30 the 10 cancel and
you just get this guy yeah as a look I'm
pretty happy with that okay so now i'm
going to subtract 3x from both sides
that'll give me this I want to get the X
by itself so while I'm at it I might as
well subtract 10 from both sides yeah I
got it from yeah
yeah 30 times at that yeah so took care
of me and then I'll see any to do before
I write down next line is to divide
through but it's not quite there is it
well it's not quite that what's the
difference it's gone wrong maybe I
should ask which is wrong Oh
so the next thing I need to do I need to
I need to cancel right so i'm going to
divide this by five and divide this by
five and that gives me rather than
negative 3 on 2 i'm thinking it's
negative 2 on three it's pretty close
isn't it like it looks like you've done
all the hard liqui all the tricky
starter better the anterior it's an easy
mistake to make isn't that i could
divide through by something i wish you
mean at this point you just I just want
to make it simpler that's all I want to
do I see there's a common factor of five
for the numerator and the denominator
someone's we get rid of it okay what do
people think satisfied yeah okay cool so
let's let's pop this off let's have a
look at number two now will do them one
at a time areas already here was to get
the sort of primitive second now what
you've got here maybe we'll help is I
did suggest to you drawing a diagram
would be really helpful for compressive
shapes like this to understand what's
going on if you're doing from orient
yourself you're just did a much higher
risk of light what is this shape and
what are the bits and pieces I need to
take apart so if I add on this like
bottom half okay you can see there's
like a big circle and then there's a
little circle and what I thought is the
difference okay by the way this some
this shape it has a special name if
you're interested in special names it's
called an annulus okay oh so you know
you guys know it like a tree trunk like
a big tree trunk if you cut it open and
then it's like it's got rings right
they're called and your dreams anyway
yeah that's right it's about years of
anyone go into it so if I think about
this problem this big problem I've got a
big circle and I need to take away a
little circle so I'm going to say area
equals and I can do two circles right I
can do two circles I need a PI R squared
I'm going to tell you why maybe you can
tell me why I have a on Capitol either
of a second I want to take away another
PI R square so you see why I've got a
big radius of the little radius so this
is just a nice easy way to say this two
of them but that's this
extra problem I actually only one half
of that do you agree with that do you
see how i unpack that right now this
like you is it going to get you any box
probably not but if I don't have a line
like this it'll be pretty hard to have
any confidence that I'm going through
this correctly and in the racking up
okay so now that I set it up I'm just
going to evaluate so I've got this heart
at the front I suppose I could take a
pie out to do you see I've got a couple
pies there too right on plus the big
radius ears have a look the big radius
is 5 so this will be 5 squared and the
little radius is 3 so let's just crunch
it through a little bit this is 25 take
away 925 take away nine is 16 16 so 16
pi over two is I think a pie and then I
was asking for it to two significant
videos so if you can go ahead and punch
in eight times pie for me i'm guessing
that'll be 20 25 yeah so if i just go
ahead and action please this week 24
point something or is it actually / 28 /
too many can someone tell what the
actual because um yep good dr. done so
now I'm going to round to my two
significant eaters 4 meters square happy
okay you see how I went through it yeah
okay I with the perimeter much the same
thing and get this ring this guy okay um
do you guys what do you want to find out
what the number is or you can 10 for me
to show you how and then you can render
itself
you want the number okay all right so
again I want to think about this three
components here or de pelo you can at
four okay there's a big semicircle or
just the art there's a little one and
then there's these two intervals these
two straight lines okay so these are the
easy bits two plus two and then I've got
to work out this guy in here this is
half what's a circumference again if
that's the area unless its first two PI
R right so i would say half time is half
cuts to say whatever all 2 times pi just
your time site yeah yeah I can but I'm
trying to like you see I can obviously i
can cancel these two right but i want to
show i'm sure i know what i'm doing
right so once these to do cancel they
become the repipe you have me back you
see how i did it i could repeat that
process again on the outside you already
told me what the big radius was so I
believe you should get 5 PI there this
guy okay because it's going to be a half
times two PI R a game but it'll be a
different ah maybe this one does that
make sense so let's have a look which
are the lengths that I'm actually adding
up for my perimeter I've got one two
three four the soul won't tell me what
um 4 plus 8 pi is equal to two severely
abused someone got it 29 yeah two to two
significant figures yeah okay I'll just
obsolete a bit because you guys can see
the desecrators stuff didn't someone say
Twain I flatten it's on today yeah cool
well done
ok last one will do this one really
quickly 3.5 is what we think it is let's
see we can confirm that ok to read
mammals for each blue marble so even
though I never said it anywhere in here
this is a ratios question ok it's like
for every one of these I've got two of
these ok so I'm going to say i want to
write it like it's red to blue is equal
to now a tuna one or is it wanted to to
line it's 22 what so you match this with
this there's with this right so red to
blue to 21 ok so that's good and then
they start doing that thirds birds and
we don't know how many marbles there are
in there ok so we're going to take
advantage of the fact that you can
convert that ratio to an equivalent one
that came to bunt defense the smallest
number i can think of would be six to
three ok i don't know if there are six
or three or sixty or thirty or whatever
but i know that they'll be in that ratio
their equivalent ok i did see some
people doing that working so what I'm
going to do is take a third of the blue
marbles right third of these away right
so that's like taking one and moving it
over to this column does that make sense
722 ok so this is like when we weren't
doing that reinvestment feel like so and
so had bonds and in their chairs and
then they move money over so I have
moved a model or a thermometer I'm one
step away from arching a question have a
look what do I have to do this thing now
yeah I want to know for each blue marble
that means for one bloom oh so I've got
to say I want that to be once i'm going
to divide through by 2 that gives me
three and a half to one which is a bit
unusual but it helps us answer the
question ok so good job man you for
nailing that first
this wonder this okay I actually get
something a bit naughty I did something
a bit annoyed so these are in fact not
the same are they right what I've done
is I've changed things based on if I
take a third of the blue marbles away a
third of these guys away and then
replace them with new models so it's
I've taken one out of this and I've
placed it into this group okay and
that's where where's the word replace
that's how I know what's happened yeah
yeah correct so the odds are the actual
answer is exactly what Barry put down
for flesh which is super fun what's
right huh I don't know all right